We strive to create a space for amazing
and courageous people to share their stories here
at the show, and in the wake of the senseless attacks
on the Asian community across our country,
many business owners and influencers are using their voice
to speak out against hate and injustice.
And we always want to use this platform to
elevate these voices.
And so, I really want you to meet our friend, Sahra Nguyen.
She is the founder of Nguyen Coffee Supply,
the first specialty Vietnamese coffee importer and roaster
in the US, and Sarah has been using her business to fight
for racial justice, one bean at a time.
And Sarah is here in the studio!
(audience woots)
Hi, Drew!
First of all, you went to UCLA
and studied Asian American studies.
What made it so important
for you to have other people's back
and fight for what you believe in?
Yeah, I think, you know, growing up in Boston,
I just felt so invisible as a young Vietnamese American kid.
And then when I discovered activism in high school, I just
I found my voice, and I found my passion
for increasing representation
because I didn't have that growing up.
See, these are why I love hearing this
because people it's like, that's your truth
of who you are as a human being.
And it's such an inspiration to other people.
Now here's a fun fact, Vietnam
number two behind Brazil for coffee production.
Yes, I don't know until 2016.
And I was like
"how do I not know this fact? I'm Vietnamese American."
Drew, it's because of lack of transparency,
and because Vietnamese coffee and farmers have
been rendered invisible in the coffee world.
Well, let's bring this into the light.
Take me through this beautiful coffee of yours.
Yeah, so I brewed you a phin drip coffee.
You flip the cap.
Yep, the cap becomes a coaster, put it over.
And I already put a dab
of sweetened condensed milk for you in the bottle.
You can stir it up.
And this is Loyalty.
It's our best-selling blend.
And it's a blend of both Arabica
and Robusta, which Vietnam is the most famous for.
Thank you for letting us shine a light
on your small business,
which is really a big thing at this show.
I learned so much
about how important it is to feature small businesses.
Whoa!
So, it's a little stronger than usual
because Robusta has two times more caffeine
than Arabica coffee beans.
There's a really delicious note
of like a beautiful bitterness
that's almost like a dark chocolate
and then I'm just getting velvet.
It's so smooth and so beautiful.
Now, how can the rest of us really be an ally
in this time where we want to support each other?
Do you have a suggestion for me
or anyone who may be watching?
First, check in with yourself,
and see if you have certain biases or stereotypes
about Asians that you don't understand, so unpack that first
because change starts inside.
And then the next thing, is to use your voice
and your platform and your privilege to have
these conversations with other people.
Because when we can start one-on-one,
it creates a ripple effect with change.
I also reached out to all
of my friends and I just said, "What can I do?
How can I be there for you?"
I love what you just shared because it shows
that being an ally and being a change-maker,
it's not a perfect path and it's not a linear path.
It's about being open to learning and stumbling and growing.
I think that's just the most important thing, right?
And so, thank you for reaching out.
You're being so honest
and vulnerable about your experience, as well.
Thank you, Sahra!
And, are we now best friends?
Yes, I hope so! Please!
Oh my God! Well, we want to continue supporting
all the good work you're doing,
which is why we're also going to buy a $5,000 cup of coffee
from your store, and we're gonna put you on the website,
the whole business.
And you are, I'm so honored
if you will be in our small businesses gift guide.
Are you kidding? Woo! Ah!
And, thank you, Sahra.
(upbeat music begins)